Welcome to the Explainer.
So how is it possible that when
1 politician cleans up a city,
it's called civic pride, but
when another does the exact same
thing, they're accused of
staging A coup?
It's a wild difference, right?
Well, today we're diving into
the power of what's called
political framing, And we're
going to see how a lot of the
time, everything really does
depend on who's holding the
broom.
OK, so here's our road map.
We'll kick things off with a
tale of two very different
cleanups.
Then we'll unpack what this
thing called a frame actually
is.
After that, we'll look at what
happens when those frames
harden, basically turning into
fossils.
And finally, we'll wrap up by
looking at what all of this
means for the rules of the game
in politics today.
All right, let's jump right in
with this central puzzle.
It's a real world political
Riddle that honestly gets to the
very heart of why things feel so
polarized right now.
So just take a look at this.
On one side, you've got Governor
Gavin Newsom cleaning up San
Francisco back in 2023 for a big
global summit.
The reaction?
Mostly positive, right?
People called it savvy staging.
Now picture this, a hypothetical
but very similar cleanup of DC
in 2025, but this time it's led
by President Trump.
The predicted label for that?
Something like a coup or urban
martial law.
Totally different.
I mean, it's the same broom,
right?
The same goal, making a city
look good.
So why on earth do we get these
two completely opposite
reactions?
What could possibly explain such
a huge gap in how people see the
exact same thing?
And here's the thing, this isn't
a new phenomenon at all.
If you look back, this has been
happening for a while.
Remember Rudy Giuliani's broken
windows policing in New York
back in the 90s?
At the exact same time it was
being praised for cleaning up
the city and condemned for how
it was done.
It just goes to show you, the
politics of public space has
always been a battleground of
perception.
OK, so the answer clearly isn't
in the act of cleaning itself.
It's got to be something else,
something deeper, more powerful
that's shaping how we see things
before we even get to the facts.
And that's something is what
experts call the frame.
So what exactly is a frame?
Well, think of it like a pair of
glasses.
It's the lens you're already
wearing when you look at a news
story.
It's this pre-existing narrative
in your head that highlights
certain facts over others.
And this is the really important
part.
It basically decides for you
what motives you think the
person has.
The pollster Franklin's had this
famous line that just nails it.
It's not what you say, it's what
they hear.
And that's it right there.
The audience's frame, what they
already believe about someone,
colors literally everything that
person says or does.
OK, let's really break this down
using our example.
The frame for Gavin Newsom is,
you know, Liberal Democrat, a
known quantity.
So his motive is assumed to be
pretty harmless, just good
optics for diplomacy.
The action is seen as just a
temporary cleanup.
But now look at the frame for
Donald Trump, dangerous
outsider.
Through that lens, the exact
same action gets a totally
different motive.
It's not about optics, it's
ideological.
It's about punishing his
enemies.
And the action itself, It's not
just a cleanup anymore.
It's seen as this huge
existential power grab.
You see, the person doing it
completely changes how the ACT
is seen.
But here's where it gets even
more intense.
What happens when these frames
stop being flexible?
You know, when they stop being
just lenses we can take on and
off and they harden into
something permanent, like a
fossil.
And that brings us to this idea
of frame lock.
Think of it as the point of no
return.
It's when the story about a
public figure gets so cemented,
so baked in, that basically no
new information, no facts, no
new events can ever change it.
Mines are made-up, period.
And this quote just says it all,
doesn't it?
Once a frame locks, facts bounce
off like hail on a tin roof.
It's such a perfect image.
The facts can be pouring down,
totally clear and objective, but
they just thing, thing, thing
bounce right off.
They can't get through that
narrative.
So what does this actually mean
in the real world?
While the effects are huge, when
someone is frame locked, their
opponents will never see
anything they do as legitimate.
It doesn't matter what the
policy is, if it comes from the
wrong person, it's bad.
And on the flip side, their
supporters will forgive or
excuse actions they would
normally condemn because it's
coming from the right person.
We get to a point where who is
doing something becomes way more
important than what is actually
being done, and this kind of
bias pops up absolutely
everywhere, not just with city
cleanups.
The article points to
immigration, which is a perfect
example.
A politician could state a
policy goal and depending on who
they are, that exact same goal
can be framed by news outlets to
sound either totally reasonable
or completely extreme.
It all depends on the
pre-existing story about that
politician.
OK, so what's the big picture?
What are the real stakes here?
Why should we care about all
this stuff like framing and
frame lock?
What does it all mean?
Well, the author argues that
what we end up with is a system
that has 2 completely different
sets of rules.
Legitimacy isn't about the
process anymore, you know about
following the rules or what you
actually did.
It becomes entirely tribal.
It's about who you are.
Your actions get the stamp of
legitimate or illegitimate based
on one thing and one thing only,
which team you play for.
And that leaves us with a really
powerful kind of chilling final
question.
If legitimacy really is just
tribal now, if one side's hero
is automatically the other
side's villain no matter what
they do, then what is that next
broom actually for?
Is it for cleaning?
Or in a world like that, will it
always be seen by the other side
as a weapon for conquering?
Something to really think about.